[Music]
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea is not an
unknown movie it gets a lot of attention
and whenever somebody mentions the name
they either think of the book or this
version but I do feel bad as a lot of
modern audiences seem to dismiss it and
to be honest I can kind of see why not
that it's bad it's actually really good
but when you have something as adult and
ground breaking point thousand leagues
under the sea and then you have the name
Walt Disney attached to it yeah a lot of
people seem to think that it's gonna be
a musical or corny and honestly it's
very adult and why I said adult I don't
mean trying to get the pg-13 rating up
by having swear words and gore and I
don't know whatever the hell pirates 3
did I'm talking about actual adult
characters actual grownups actual good
dialogue actual intriguing ideas yeah
remember those you could still get away
with that with a G rating and still have
it be a live-action film bunking ahead
of myself what's the story
well there's rumors of a giant sea
monster that's apparently taking down a
lot of ships so one ship is sent out to
try and find it and destroy it
two of the crew members are Kirk Douglas
and Peter Lorre but once the suppose at
sea mustard destroys that ship our two
heroes along with another survivor swim
aboard this sea monster apparently and
discover that's actually a submarine at
a time when really there were no
submarines this submarine is led by
Captain Nemo played by James Mason
that's 30 pretty damn big stars at the
time right there James Mason Kirk
Douglas and Peter Lorre all very
distinct in their acting styles and work
off each other very well
what's Nemo's plan it turns out he's
sick of humanity and the world so he
decides to retire to the sea but he's so
sick of all the misery and war that
humanity makes for itself that he
decides to step in and try to destroy
anything he sees as disrupting the peace
he's cold and Stern was just trying to
do what he feels is best for all of
mankind he doesn't trust our castaways
but over time he does manage to open up
to him treating him less like prisoners
and more like members of the crew as
Disney films go this is probably the
most subdued and that's saying a lot
seeing how there's a giant squid that
attacks there are some really
groundbreaking of and some really
good visuals the smart dialog and the
development of the characters is so
clear-cut bet it's hard not to like them
their ideologies their intelligence
their characteristics everything about
them makes them so distinct but also so
enjoyable the effects are also really
something this squid probably will be
done with CG nowadays but back then they
just used a life-size puppet originally
it was shot during the day and Disney
said it looked too fake so he
recommended that they do it in a storm
that way it hides this strings a lot
better the idea of shooting a monster
and a storm err in the dark in order to
hide wet looks like would be used years
later both for atmosphere and to hide
the technicals behind making it
there's definitely changes from the book
but I feel it really still got the
spirit of both the characters and the
technology really well and even when
they're doing something as silly as
fighting a giant squid or using
electricity to fight off these natives
it still works because of the dedication
of both the atmosphere and the actors
it's kind of like with Indiana Jones
yeah when you get down to it it's a
pretty stupid story but Harrison Ford's
performance and just how seriously the
direction is taking it makes it one of
the great action classics and while this
is really an action film per se I'd say
it does make some really big strong
stands for sci-fi and fantasy but I
guess that's why it has such a hard time
finding such a dedicated audience fans a
typical Disney probably won't get into
so much dialogue and so much technical
talk and only one or two fight sequences
but fans of that stuff probably can't
get too much into like say Kirk Douglas
is little musical number or the fact
they as a psychic seal but for me I
think they blend perfectly it has just
enough to keep kids from falling asleep
but it also has just enough for the
parents not to change the channel I
think it's a good mix even if it does
lean more towards the adult side which
now that adult I find I like even more
it's got good adventure good actors and
good talent telling one of the most
famous sci-fi stories of all time I say
it's definitely worth checking
[Music]